so i had a relationship with rick ross
because shakir signed rick ross in
cheesy so the first two albums rick ross
did he recorded in the uh um in the
office where i interned
yeah okay so i built a relationship with
strong relationship with him and um
gucci pucci
um so you know they just saw my come up
and you know i would shake little guys
so you know they always kept the
eye on me um so when i got to
warner brothers the first day on the job
i just called ross like
you got to bring maybach over here it's
wide open you know so you were very
instrumental in bringing that oh
absolutely
because me and ross was super tight you
know i pretty much like you know joey
helped me put it together because joey
was the boss so
you know it was like you know my
relationship but you know
obviously you know you got joey todd
moskowitz and lyra cohen who are the
chairmans and people who are running the
company and i'm i'm the
you know the lowest level a r so you
know through my relationship i brought
the meeting to them we had the meeting
together
you know rick ross expressed to them you
know how important me being involved
with it would be if he did the deal
there
and we got the deal done two weeks later
i remember how big of a deal that was
because i remember
you know my boy lee was over at warner
brothers and lovely
love that guy yeah good guy there was
like no hip-hop though
it was nothing it was like yeah it was
like it was like dry as [ __ ] it was jill
scott i think
and then and then uh mmg coming over at
the time ross is the hottest thing
moving yes
meek is the hottest thing in the streets
yeah and people in wales
and then even was moving
absolutely and and i just remember that
moment was so big bro
yeah that's history yeah so they so you
i didn't even realize i didn't even know
that you you helped bring that situation
over yeah that's what like got me to
start it as far as just getting some
credibility because from there you know
me and wale did lotus flower bomb yeah
and
put out wales project that did super
well when number one
then from there um i did meek
dream chasers 2 and dreams and
nightmares and i pretty much did
every mmg project that came out on the
warner brothers system until we even
transferred over to atlantic